The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So today,
we'll start with a demo,
so Pepe will be on stage.
And then we'll continue with
the lectures on the gratings.
Pepe, whenever you're
ready, you can--
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO: OK.
Can we-- so today,
the goal today
is to show you a couple of
very interesting experiments.
And again, the idea
of this is for you
to see all these derivations
that we've been doing actually
applied in a real experiment
and see the results
that you would expect.
And for instance, these
last [? pieces, ?]
you were supposed to compute the
interference between a couple--
two plane waves propagating
at a different angle,
so you were supposed
to also calculate
analytical solution of that.
Now, we're going to see the
real evidence of that solution.
So for that, we actually built,
in this case, a little more
elaborate setup than the ones
that we've been showing before.
This actually a
Mach-Zehnder interferometer
that Professor Sheppard
described last time,
and I will explain
it very briefly.
Can we zoom out, please?
Controls?
I guess maybe
that's the maximum.
All right, so we start
here with a laser.
So the laser comes
from this side,
and up to this section
here is where we just
collimate the
light, so basically,
what I'm going to focus right
now is on this other section.
So after this part here,
we have a nice plane wave.
This component
here is a polarizer
that, right now, just
take it as an element that
allows me to control
the intensity such
that the CCD doesn't
receive too much light.
Now, these two pieces of glass
here are the beam splitters.
So we've seen that these beam
splitters-- basically what
they do is that they will
split a section of the beam
to one side and a section of
the beam to the other side.
In this case, it's
50/50 percent.
Now, then, we have two mirrors.
So as you can see,
there's one path here,
and the other path here.
The two paths that
now are going to be
combined by this second
beam splitter here.
Sometimes, this is
called a beam combiner.
And then they co-propagate here,
pass through this iris here,
and then in this case,
they're reflecting-- again,
these mirror are
going to the CCD.
So essentially, what we have
here is these two plane waves
that first are splitted and
then are combined back again
together.
And if the two plane waves
are exactly in line--
we see that we're not
supposed to see fringes
because they are
exactly in line,
but we learned also that if we
introduce a little angle here,
now the planar wavefronts of
each plane wave will interfere,
and then we're going to see
some sinusoidal pattern.
So this is exactly the same
as in the [? pieces. ?] One
of the problems that had what
would be the interference
pattern in an xy
plane in this case.
In an xy plane,
[INAUDIBLE] two plane waves
propagating with a slightly
different k vectors.
So now, let's look at
the interference pattern.
Now, this is here in
my computer screen.
So this is a video, real
time, of this interferometer.
So as you can see, you
get very nice fringes
of very bright and
very dark, so we
know that the
peaks are the proof
of constructive interference,
the null destructive
interference.
And you also see
some vibration here,
because we said that
these type of instruments
are very, very, very sensitive
to environmental conditions,
and I'm actually going
to tap the table.
Even if I just blow
some air, but I
want to get some moisture
in there, in the optics,
but you can see
variations of the fringes.
So then these type
of interferometers
are used for
different measurements
to calculate, for
instance, phases or measure
different profiles of
reflective optics, et cetera.
So there are many
applications of
these Mach-Zehnder
interferometers,
and the reason being
the sensitivity.
Now, we also talked
about another thing--
the period of this sinusoidal
pattern that we see
is proportional to the
angle of the plane waves.
So in this case, I'm going to
move one of the mirrors-- say,
this mirror here--
to change one of the beam paths.
The other one is
going to remain fixed.
So let me tilt it a little bit
and see what happens first.
So we see that the period of
the plane wave is changing.
In this case, I'm moving
it in in the y direction.
So now the period is larger.
Does anyone want to tell me why
do you think it's happening?
Are the plane waves
more close to be
parallel, or further away?
Yep?
STUDENT: Appears inversely
proportional to theta,
so your period's smaller data.
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO:
Yes, exactly.
So essentially,
here, by doing this,
I'm making the plane waves
to be as in line as I can.
And of course, since I'm
increasing the period,
also the oscillations
will start increasing,
and now, we get these
artifacts due to the frame
rate of the camera that are
going to be very noticeable,
I suppose, in Singapore.
That's why I started
with a small fringe.
I can also change the
tilting of the fringe
to do nice things like
this by basically changing
the orientation of the mirrors.
All right, so now
what I'm going to do
is I'm going to block
one of these beam paths.
So we have a nice
plane wave here,
and now, we are going
to repeat the aperture,
this lead experiment
that I showed last time.
But today, we're going to
do it in different L regime.
So basically, we're going
to try to mimic physically
the experiment that
Professor Barbastathis showed
in the video that he showed
in, I think, last lecture.
All right, so we
have this slate here.
Let me get it down a little bit.
And I need to control
the intensity,
so I'm going to move
this closer to the CCD.
This is as close as I can get.
So as you can see, there
is a plane wave hitting--
let me just reduce the exposure.
There is a plane wave
hitting this slate,
and you can see the
diffraction here happening
in the discontinuity
when basically it
hits the metal piece.
And I can tune the size
here, and of course,
if I make this larger,
the diffraction effects
appear less noticeable.
But for a smaller slate--
let's do that-- it's
actually pretty nice.
We see the nice
diffraction, but I'm
going to increase
intensity, so you can see
the fringes that happen there.
Now, let's see what
happens if I have it--
I fixed position, so
the size of this slate,
and now I'm going to move it
along the optical axis back.
So I'm propagating back.
Let me just reduce the intensity
here, so we are somewhere here.
So now, I'm going
to go back, and you
can see how the diffraction
pattern changes.
And this is
essentially the video.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Can you hear me?
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO: Yes.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Can you go back
where the fringe in
the center was dark?
Yeah, something like that.
This is the equivalent of
the Poisson blinking spot
that we mentioned.
Go a little bit
closer to the camera.
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO:
Go a little bit what?
I'm sorry.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: A little
bit closer to the camera.
Yeah.
Try to have the center dark.
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO: Oh,
I'm going to show the Poisson
spot with a circular
aperture a bit later--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
But I want to make
a point about this case.
In this case, you can see,
again, the Poisson spot,
but it's actually an entire
dark line in the center.
That's because the
scattering of the two edges
is actually out of phase,
so that the interference
destructively at the center,
and you see an entire dark band.
And then of course, in this
case, with a circular aperture,
you see the Poisson
spot as a spot.
In this case, it
is a vertical bar.
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO:
There you go.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Yeah, that's perfect.
Perfect, yeah.
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO: So
here, you see the blinking.
So this is dark, and
this would be bright.
This would be the
blinking line, I suppose.
Now, let me change it to
the other video that we saw,
that was the circular aperture.
So this is a circular
aperture of a fixed size.
In this case, you can see,
when it's close to the camera,
again, as close as
I can get it to,
you see refraction patterns.
So now, this is very
nice, because what
we're supposed to
see here, again,
is going to be that famous
Poisson spot or blinking spot.
And before we see the
results that we, again,
saw in the movie, there's a nice
historical story about these.
In [INAUDIBLE],, Fresnel spent
a very nice paper to a contest
about the refraction of light.
So at the time,
remember that there
was all this controversy of
is light a wave or a particle.
So in the committee
judging these papers,
Poisson, a very
respected scientist,
was actually in the committee.
And he saw Fresnel's
paper, and he was
like, no, this has to be wrong.
And he wanted to disprove it,
so he actually went and did
some calculations
and then proved
that, if Fresnel was
right, what this means
is that if you have, say, an
opening like this, somewhere
behind that opening, after
shining it with a plane wave,
you're supposed to
see a dark spot.
And that dark spot is
very counterintuitive
because, basically,
you're supposed to see,
from the geometrical optics,
all the light going straight
through.
So how could there be a very
dark spot in the center?
So then basically, he
said, no, this is the proof
that Fresnel's theory is wrong.
But then another member in the
committee, Dominique Arago,
he actually went ahead
and did the experiment,
and he saw this Poisson
spot experimentally.
And then thanks to
that, of course,
Fresnel won the contest.
And now this, I guess, as
opposed to-- like as occurs
to Poisson--
it's called a Poisson spot.
All right, let's see the
Poisson spot in action.
So I'm going to go-- here,
you see it in bright, dark.
I'm going to go
even further away.
So I'm moving it back, and
you see the blinking spot.
Trying to do it slowly.
Going to go back.
Can you see it in Singapore?
I guess that was a yes.
Cool.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: They're
very beautiful actually.
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO:
Yes, they're very nice.
So can we switch to the
front camera, please?
Control?
Can we switch to
the front camera?
So now, the next thing
that I'm going to show--
it's a diffraction grating.
So diffraction gratings--
it's a very interesting
optical component.
The front view, please.
I'm going to show something
with a piece of paper.
Or I guess if not, I'm
going to show it here.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO:
I'm sorry?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
explained [INAUDIBLE]..
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO: OK.
So the next thing
that I'm going to show
is an optical component,
that is very used
in practicing different
optical setups, that
is called a grating.
So grating-- you can think of
it as a material, in this case,
that--
the one that I'm going to show
is called a phase grating.
Basically, the index or
refraction within the material
varies in a given way-- in
this case, sinusoidally.
So it's a periodic variation
of the index of refraction,
and then when the light
hits this element, looks
like a flat piece of
glass, but in reality, it
has this index
varying, it basically
decomposes in multiple angles.
And what I'm going to
show here, in this case,
is a normal laser
pointer, but it actually
has two set of gratings
in this little end.
So what we are going
to see, again, now,
is we're going to see some
beautiful array of patterns.
You see them?
And actually, I'm going
to project them here.
This, I'm not sure
if the Singapore
side is going to see it or not.
So now, I have to
cross linear gratings.
I actually can put
them in things,
so I can see very nice spots.
I can open them, and you can do
all sorts of fun things here.
So the optical
component actually
looks something like this.
This is the second time
that I showed a grating.
The first time was in
the very first demo,
when I used the grating
to disperse light,
similar to a prism.
So if you remember, I
had a prism dispersing
in what is called a
normal dispersion,
and a grating with
what is called
the anomalous dispersion.
So this also, if you
shine it with white light,
will form a very,
very nice rainbow.
So in this case, it's a bit hard
to show this guy with a camera,
but I'm going to try, if we
can put-- the overhead camear
I think is on.
So what I'm going to do is
going to increase the intensity.
And use the aperture,
and I'm going
to try to show it in
a piece of paper here.
So you see here,
the three spots,
in this case, of
this element being,
in this case, more orders.
So each of these spot we
call a diffraction order.
The one that goes straight
through would be the 0 order.
Then we go to plus/minus 1,
plus/minus 2, so on and so
forth, and I guess
after these, we're
going to do the
actual derivation,
the mathematical
derivation of this.
You want to add something else,
George, for the grating side?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
I think this only
had the plus/minus 1,
plus/minus 3, and a very weak 0?
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO:
Let's see.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Because
I only saw four spots,
so it must have been--
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO:
There's more, I think.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Oh, OK.
Not very visible.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
There's more.
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO: Yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
0 is also present,
but you can see that the
plus/minus 2, plus/minus 4
are missing.
We'll talk about
this in class later.
The point to see here is that
you see the pattern is not
quite regular.
It looks like there
is one missing
order between the last--
if you label the central
one 0, then it goes 1,
and then it keeps 2,
and then it goes to 3.
So that's the point
I wanted to make.
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO: Good.
So I think we switch
back to you, George.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Thank you, Pepe.
JOSE DOMINGUEZ-CABALLERO:
You're welcome.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: I
feel jealous actually
because this is much better
to see it in real life
than it is to see it in math.
But hopefully,
this will motivate
you to tolerate
the math, because
if the physical phenomena
are so pretty, maybe
it is worthwhile to go to the
effort of understanding them,
I suppose.
So today, I will talk--
I will basically pick
up where Pepe left,
and I will talk about
diffraction gratings.
Oh, before I forget,
some of you asked if you
could have the movies from--
the animations that they
played in class the other day.
So if you go to the website,
I have created a new section
called Animations.
And I've put the
movies as AVI files,
so you can download
them from there.
And also I have
revised the notes.
Last time, if you recall, we
caught a couple of factors of 2
that were missing, and
so on and so forth.
So I fixed those.
If you find any more errors
in the notes, please let me
know so that I can
fix them as well.
So today, we'll talk about--
so basically, I will
describe, mathematically,
what Pepe showed in real life.
So a grating basically,
as Pepe mentioned,
is a periodic,
thin transparency.
So we've talked about thin
transparencies before.
We mentioned that they
modulate in general.
Thin transparencies
modulate the amplitude
and the phase of the
optical field, so
in that particular case,
when the thin transparency's
a periodic function of space,
then we'll call it a grating.
And I guess for clarity
of presentation,
it is customary to classify
gratings as amplitude or phase,
depending on whether
the grating acts
upon the magnitude of
the electromagnetic field
or the phase of the
electromagnetic field.
Now, this can cause a
little bit of confusion
because we have
agreed to use the term
amplitude to denote the complex
amplitude of the optical field.
Confusingly enough, when people
talk about amplitude gratings,
they should be calling
them magnitude gratings,
because as you can see
in the case on the left,
the transmission function
of an amplitude grating
is a positive real number.
So therefore, this
kind of grating
acts directly onto the
magnitude of the optical field.
Nevertheless, for
historical reasons,
people call these are gratings--
I suppose they call
them magnitude--
I'm sorry, they call
them amplitude gratings.
So hopefully, this will
not create confusion.
But anyway, the simplest
possible modulation
is sinusoidal, and
you can see here
sort of juxtaposed in
a sinusoidal amplitude
grating and the
sinusoidal phase grating.
So starting with the
amplitude grating,
the complex transmission
function of the grating
is actually not complex at all.
It is a real positive
number, and what I've done
is, on top of it, I've
plot its magnitude,
which is, of course,
itself since this
is a real positive
function, and its phase.
And of course, the phase
is 0 because the phase
of a complex number,
which happens
to be real and positive, is 0.
The quantities to mention here
are the period of the grating.
We use the upper case
Greek symbol lambda, which
looks like a hat, I guess.
That symbol is called lambda.
So this is the period of the
grating, so in this case,
you can see the grating
seems to fulfill
one undulation
between approximately
minus 5 units and plus 5 units.
Therefore, the period
here is 10 units.
And actually, the unit I've
picked on the horizontal axis
is the wavelength of the
light, so this grating
has a period of 10 wavelengths.
So if the light were a visible--
green light has a wavelength
of approximately half
a micrometer, so in real
units for the green light,
the period here would have been
approximately 5 micrometers
or 10 wavelengths.
Then m-- we saw
the symbol m also
when we talk about interference.
We called m the contrast
between the brightest
and the darkest part of a fringe
in the case of an interference
pattern.
In this case, we still
call it contrast,
but it is between the
most transmissive part
of the grating and the
darkest part of the grating.
So this case, you can see that
it goes between approximately
0.9 and 0.1.
The maximum
transmissivity is 0.9,
and the minimum
transmissivity is 0.1.
So therefore, of the value of
m for the grating shown here
is approximately 0.8.
If the grating was swinging
between maximum 100%
transmission, totally
bright and totally dark,
that would have been 0.
Then the contrast
would've been 1.
So this is the function
of this m parameter here.
And finally, we allow a phase
shift, which basically says,
if the maximum--
since the grating is written
as a cosine function here,
phi tells me if the maximum
transmission, the maximum value
of the cosine, is
centered with x equals 0
on the horizontal axis--
so you can see that, in this
case, it is indeed center.
So therefore, the
phase phi would equal 0
in the grating
shown in this case.
So that's what I had
to say about that.
Under the grating, I should
go to the phase grating.
It is actually kind
of the opposite.
So the phase
grating is expressed
as a complex exponential
with a purely--
with a pure phase without
any amplitude modulation.
So it's magnitude then is 1.
So you see that the
magnitude is a flat function,
so this means that this grating
transmits all of the light.
What it does do, though,
is it modulates the phase,
and you can see that
it modulates the phase
in a sinusoidal fashion.
So this is what you see now
in the bottom plot, which
is that the phase, the angle--
by the way, the
phase, sometimes we
denote the phase as this angular
symbol of a complex number.
So the phase is simply the
argument of the exponent here,
and is, itself, sinusoidal.
And it also has a
period and a contrast.
The contrast in this case
is called the phase contrast
because we're talking
about the phase,
and you can see
that, in this case,
it is swinging also
approximately between plus 0.4
and minus 0.4.
So the contrast is
also 0.8 in this case,
but it could be anything,
really, between minus pi and pi
to get a complete
phase contrast.
The other two
parameters are the same.
The period is also
about 10 wavelengths,
and the phase shift is 0.
We have to be a little
bit careful here not
to confuse the phase of the
grating with the phase shift.
So again, the phase
shift is telling us
whether that transmission
is aligned or no
with the origin of
the coordinates.
So this case,
since I have a sine
in the phase of the
grating, you see
that it assumes the
value 0 at x equals 0,
so again, there's
no phase shift.
So this phase shift is not to
be confused with the phase delay
that the grating imposes
upon the complex amplitude
of the electromagnetic field.
So that's another
important point,
and I would like
to point it out.
So how do these
things behave now?
So what I will do is I
will play two movies, which
I guess are not as
convincing as the movies
that Pepe showed because
Pepe is doing an experiment.
In this case, these are
simply Matlab calculations.
But basically, the two movies
will show you two great things.
One is an amplitude grating,
and one is a phase grating.
And it will show you how the
field propagates after grating.
And these movies are also
posted to the website
so you can play them
yourselves again later.
Now, I should say, the grating
grooves are oriented horizontal
in this case, and you cannot
see them on the camera
or on the video because the
pixel size is not big enough
to allow you to see
them, unfortunately.
This is an artifact
of the calculation.
So what you see here
is some variation
of the grating that is actually
not the grating itself.
As I said it, is
called a moire pattern,
if you are familiar
with the term.
But anyway, I don't want to
go into moire theory here,
but the reason you
can see this pattern
is because the pixel size
of the camera in the display
is not small enough to show
you the period of the grating.
So the grating is actually
expressed by this function.
X is the same in the
equation as in the axis,
and the period of the
grating is 2 wavelengths.
So this grating has a
very, very small period.
The contrast I picked
to be 1 in this case,
and there's no phase shift.
So I will play the movie now,
and you will see what happens.
So the field will
propagate along the z-axis,
and you can see that the light
that originally illuminated
the grating actually now
splits into three parts.
These are, also Pepe mentioned,
called diffraction orders.
One of them propagates
straight through.
That is called the
0 diffraction order,
and then you get a plus 1 above
and a minus 1 diffraction order
below.
So this is the typical behavior
of a sinusoidal amplitude
grating.
Now, if I play the same
thing for the first grating,
there's two things to notice.
First of all, there's
no moire at all here.
That's because the
phase grating does not
modulate the magnitude of
the electric field at all.
So in other words,
at the entrance
toward the grating
itself, the grating
looks just like an
empty transparency.
It has not changed the
magnitude of the field.
What it has done, it
has changed the phase,
and because the
phase of the field
got modulated inside
this slit over here,
what you will see when I
play the grating is, again,
that it splits.
But now, it splits
into more than one.
It splits into, in this case,
you can see very clearly
five diffraction orders.
You can see very
clearly, there is
one in the center, then
another one and another one.
So these are the plus 1, plus
2, and then at the bottom,
you have minus 1, minus
2 diffraction orders.
So it is, in some ways,
similar to the amplitude case,
but in this case, we'll get
more diffraction orders.
And so I guess what I
would like to do now
is I will try to explain
what is the difference,
and why the phase grating gives
us more diffraction order.
I should say, by the way,
that the sinusoidal--
I want to emphasize the
sinusoidal amplitude
grating gives us only three--
the 0 order, the plus
1, and the minus 1.
In general, other
types of gratings,
for example binary or
phase gratings and so on,
they give us more than
three diffraction orders.
So first of all, let's look
at the physical picture.
So I'll start with the
sinusoidal amplitude
because this is the
simplest possible grating,
and let's look at the physical
picture of what's going on here
and why we get this
diffraction order.
So if I have a plane
wave impinging-- oh,
so again, this symbol, being
Greek, I have an advantage,
I guess.
I can recognize it.
It is the uppercase
lambda, so we'll
use the symbol lowercase--
control, may I have the paper?
Actually, I already
have the paper, do I?
Yeah.
So this symbol that we
use for the wavelength
is the lowercase lambda.
This symbol that we use
generally for a special period
is the uppercase.
It may sound a
little bit ridiculous
that I emphasize it so much, but
believe me, in previous years,
all the generations of students
have been endlessly confused
by the lambda and the lambda.
So I would like
to emphasize it--
these are two different symbols.
We use the lower case
for the wavelength
and the upper case for
the spatial period.
So that's it then.
That's the period, and
the inverse of that--
the inverse of a period
generally is a frequency.
So since now we have a spatial
period, the inverse [? u0, ?]
we'll call this
special frequency.
And let's illuminate
this grating now
with an incident plane wave.
So throughout this lecture, I
will be illuminating gratings
with plane waves on axis.
In the homework that
I've posted today,
and actually just became
visible a few minutes ago,
in the homework,
you will see what
happens if you illuminate the
grating with a tilted plane
wave or with a spherical wave.
This is also possible.
You can illuminate a
grate in any way you like.
Now, we'll start with
the simplest case,
which is on axis plane wave.
So we don't know yet
what's going to happen,
but we know one thing.
We know Huygen's principal,
and Huygen's says
that, at each point where
the grating is transmissive,
we'll get point sources.
So of course, I do not
only get only these two,
I get the point
source here, which
is very strong because this is
the location where the grating
has maximum transmission.
Next to it, I will
get another point--
another Huygen's point source
that is slightly attenuated.
Then next to it, another
one that is slightly more
attenuated, another
one, another one.
There comes a point here where
the grating is totally black,
that it is totally absorbing.
Therefore, there's is a missing
Huygen's source over here,
and then as I move on
along the optical axis,
I will get more Huygen's point
sources that are progressively
less attenuated.
And then finally, I
get over here where
I have another strong,
as strong as possible,
Huygen's point source.
So we derived an integral.
Professor Sheppard last week
[INAUDIBLE] of an integral that
allows us to basically
sum the contributions
from all these
Huygen's point sources
and derive different
L diffracted field
after the grating.
So of course, this integral,
we call the Fresnel integral,
and here is another linguistic
lesson-- this time in French,
not in Greek.
This is pronounced "Freh-nell."
The S is silent.
So if you go to a conference,
and you say "Fres-nell,"
people will conclude that
you don't know optics.
So part of knowing
optics is part
of knowing the French and the
Greek language, I suppose.
I'm joking, of course,
but it's still actually,
professionals are like
children, who are vicious.
If we see someone make a
silly mistake like this,
say "Fres-nell"
instead of "Freh-nell,"
we make fun of them.
And you don't want
to be made fun
of in a professional setting.
So always remember, this
is pronounced "Freh-nell,"
not "Fres-nell."
So the Fresnel
integral, therefore,
allows us to compute the
field, the diffracted field,
after the grating.
But we will not do it here
because the Fresnel integral,
in this case, is awful.
It is very difficult to compute.
However, I will show
you that, by using
very simple physical
arguments, we can nevertheless
derive the Fresnel
diffracted field anyway
without making use of this
nasty Fresnel integral.
So let's go back to our
Huygen's picture here.
I would just consider this two
point sources of Huygen's which
are the strongest.
And this is, of course,
an approximation,
a simplification, but
it will still give us
the correct physical picture.
That's why I'm doing it.
So basically, over
here, you can see
that these are point sources,
so they basically emit light
in all possible directions.
So I will pick one
arbitrary direction,
and I will call it theta.
So here is a ray, if you
wish, a ray emanating
from this Huygen's point
source at angle theta,
and here's another ray emanating
from the next Huygen's point
source at the same angle theta.
Now, these rays-- are they
the same or different?
Geometrical optics
says they're the same,
but now, we know better.
We know that these
are not really bullets
that propagate like particles.
These are actually waves.
And if you compare
the wave emitted here
and the wave emitted
there, if you draw a line
perpendicular to these waves,
this would be the wavefront.
So you can see, easily now,
that if you compare the wave
on the lower ray with a
wave with the upper ray,
you can see that the wave in the
lower ray is actually delayed.
It has traveled the
longer distance.
Therefore, it is delayed by
a certain amount with respect
to the ray that is below.
And the way, of course,
to compute this delay
is to draw an orthogonal
triangle here.
This side of the triangle
is actually the wavefront.
is the phase delay,
and the hypotenuse of the
triangle is the period--
is the special
period of the grating
that we denoted as lambda.
So by using the
Pythagoras theorem,
then, we can actually
compute the phase delay,
and we can compute--
there's, of course, a typo here.
Let me fix it right away, and
I will post a fix in the notes.
Anyway, I think it's better
if I don't fix it now,
but the correct equation over
there should say the optical
path length difference--
that's what OPLD means--
equals lambda, the grating
period, times sine theta.
Sorry about that.
These notes came from
another old [? convention ?]
where the period
was denoted as d.
So with this little
fix, that OPLD
equals the period of the
grating times sine theta,
we can see now that, if
this quantity of OPLD
equals a wavelength, then the
two rays are actually in phase.
And not only one
wavelength-- it might
equal two wavelengths,
three wavelengths,
any integral number
of wavelengths.
Then these two
waves are in phase.
Therefore, they
interfere constructively.
And this is the key, now--
the constructive interference
of waves in these specific,
now, directions is what we
call diffraction orders,
that Pepe very beautifully
showed you earlier.
And you also saw them in
my simulation in Matlab.
And so q here, the
quantity q, is an integer.
It is meant to
denote an integer,
and we can derive this now.
So we can derive the sine
of the angle of the q,
over the qth, I guess,
diffraction order where
qth might be first,
second, third, and so on.
So q runs 1, 2, 3, and so on.
And of course,
because typically, we
operate in the
paraxial approximation,
we can also drop the
sign here and say simply
that the plus/minus
1 diffraction
order is propagating
at an angle that
is given by this
ratio over there,
the ratio of the
small Greek lambda
to the big Greek lambda, that
is the ratio of the wavelength
over the period.
And you can see
immediately, for example,
that if I make the
grating period smaller
than the wavelength,
I will get in trouble
because this sine over there
will attempt to become bigger
than 1.
Anybody knows what
happens in this case
if I make the grating
period smaller than lambda,
than the wavelength?
Mr. [INAUDIBLE]?
Yeah, actually, I can do--
I can make a period
smaller than a wavelength.
What will happen
then is I will get
what is called an
evanescent wave,
so I will not get a
diffraction order anymore.
I'll get an evanescent
wave from the grating,
and this is a term
that we've seen before.
We haven't defined
yet, mathematically,
but I want to alert you that,
basically, an evanescent
wave is an exponential
decay of a diffracted field.
So you do not quite get a
diffracted order anymore.
For the purposes of the class,
in the next few lectures
at least, definitely for the
next three or four weeks,
we will assume that the
grating period is much larger
than the wavelength.
So therefore, this quantity
is always less than 1,
and the sine is always
properly less than 1.
And we can solve it, so we can
get the real and not evanescent
diffraction order.
I think my computer--
so as I said
before, the plus 1--
this is actually arbitrary.
I can call plus 1--
by convention, the plus
1 is the one that goes--
if we denote the light--
as in geometrical
optics, the light
always goes from left to right.
And the angle is
positive if it is acute
measured counterclockwise
from the optical axis.
So that is why this is the
plus first diffraction order.
It has a positive propagation
angle, and then the one
that has negative
propagation angle,
we'll call it minus
first diffraction order.
The 0th diffraction
order is the one
that has theta equals 0
that is propagating on axis.
That is also known as a DC term.
Now, for those of you who
are electrical engineers,
the term DC already alerts
you to some kind of a Fourier
transform or some kind of
a frequency representation.
We will see later that, indeed,
light propagating on axes
can be thought of as the
equivalent of a DC component
in Fourier series decomposition.
For now, let's take it
as a term, as a sort of--
what do you call
this-- as a jargon,
and we'll see later why
we call this the DC term.
This is a mathematical
derivation
that we can do in order
to actually become
a little bit more quantitative
and a little bit more correct.
So the mathematical
definition is very simple.
We start with the
expression for the grating.
Then we decompose the
cosine into the two
complex exponentials that
we can [? write ?] it.
And then what we do is we
simply make a substitution
according to the equation
that I saw before already.
We say that 1 over lambda
equals sine theta upon lambda.
This may seem arbitrary,
but I can always
do it because lambda--
I'm sorry [INAUDIBLE].
Uh-oh, we're out of focus.
Anyway, you cannot
see the question,
but you can certainly see
this substitution here.
And I cannot-- thank you.
So we can always
do the substitution
by defining sine theta to be
the ratio of the wavelength
over the period,
and we can also make
a substitution of [? u0, ?]
the special frequency as I
defined it before.
The point is not that.
The point is that each
one of these terms
actually is recognizable
as a plane wave.
And now, we'll really
need my transparency here.
So if you recall, when
we derived plane waves--
we did this some time ago.
Actually, I think
Professor Sheppard did it
in the context of
electromagnetics.
The way we write a
plane wave is like this.
These are what you will see
if you go back into your notes
by about two or three lectures.
If you have a plane
wave propagating
in the direction
of this arrow here,
then the expression
that I put above
is actually the phasor for
the electromagnetic field
describing that plane wave.
And if, in addition, we say that
the grating is at z equals 0--
which I can always do.
I can define my axis so that
the grating is located at
z equals 0--
then this term will
actually disappear.
And you can recognize
now this expression
that is left for the plane
wave is the same that you have
already here with
the complex exponent,
provided you make the
substitution that we
had before, provided you
make the substitution--
this one.
With a substitution,
the grating itself
becomes like the expression
for not just one, but actually
three plane waves.
And what are the
three plane waves?
Well, here is one, which is the
plus first diffraction order.
There's a plane wave
propagating at angle theta.
Then the next one, the
constant is actually
the DC term that
propagates on axis,
because if you substitute
theta equals 0 here,
then this entire thing
disappears, so you just
have the constant.
That is a plane wave
propagating on axis.
And finally, this
term is propagating
at the negative
angle, and this is
what you call the minus
1 diffraction order.
So this may seem a little bit
like mathematical trickery,
but has a very nice
physical interpretation,
if only you recall our
convention for the phasor
expression of plane waves.
The rest is relatively
straightforward.
A sinusoidal phase
grating, as Pepe mentioned,
is basically a
grating which does not
modulate the amplitude, but
the phase of the optical field.
And you can do it in two ways.
One is what I saw here.
That is known as a
surface relief grating,
which has been processed.
Typically, this is
done by chemical--
by optical exposure and then
chemical development, that
causes the surface
of, typically,
a polymer or a properly prepared
colloidal, colloidal glass.
It causes the surface to pick
up a sinusoidal modulation
like this.
So because the material
has a refractive index n,
you can see that
light, depending
if you take a ray, depending
on where it hits this material,
it might suffer a
different phase delay.
Another way that
Pepe mentioned is you
might actually have a
flat piece of material
and modulate the index
of refraction inside.
Again, that would
have a similar effect.
The complex transmission
function would be of this form.
It would be an
exponential whose value
depends upon the optical
thickness of the material
that the light went through.
You can see the period here,
and you can see the phase delay.
So the phase delay,
of course, depends
on the difference between
the index of refraction
inside the material and
in the surrounding
middle that is air.
So that's the
expression over there,
and this is, of course,
the phase contrast
that we mentioned before,
when we defined the grating.
And in order, now,
to figure out what
happens after this
grating, I will
have to resort to mathematical,
again, trickery, I guess.
If you go to books
of optical tables,
you can find very easily
that this expression can also
be written as a
sum, as a sum that
involves some kind of
nasty Bessel functions.
We don't even have
to worry about this,
but what we will go
ahead and add in a second
is that each one of
these Bessel functions
corresponds to diffraction
order for this grating.
And the way you can see this
is if you rewrite the grating
like this.
So this is now simply using
a mathematical formula,
but now, if you actually do
the same trick I did here,
if you recognize that each one
of these complex exponentials
basically corresponds
to the plane wave,
then you can see that
what I've written there,
it came out of a book of
mathematical formulas,
but physically, it
contains an amplitude
that is given by the value
of a Bessel function.
But then more importantly,
it contains a sequence
of plane waves that are
known as diffraction orders,
and the propagation angle of
the plane wave indexed by q
is given by this explanation
here, the same expression
that they had before.
So these are then the
diffraction orders
for the sinusoidal
phase grating.
Even more generally,
if you don't
have a sinusoidal
grating, but still
some kind of a periodic
grating with arbitrary shape,
and also possibly you
might even have absorption,
so this grating truly
implements a complex amplitude
transmission, which is
nevertheless periodic.
You may recall from
your basic math
that you have an arbitrary
complex periodic function,
you can write it as
a Fourier series.
And in this case,
the Fourier series
also has the same
physical meaning
as the one I did before,
the Fourier series
expansion coefficients.
And actually, the amplitudes
and the harmonics-- these
are called harmonics,
if you recall.
The harmonics of the
Fourier series themselves
now correspond to plane
waves that were previously
called diffraction orders.
So then you can see
that each Fourier series
coefficient actually corresponds
to a separate diffraction
order.
And in addition, recall, again,
Professor Sheppard last week.
He mentioned that if you
have an optical field,
and you take the magnitude
squared of its phasor,
then what you get is actually
the amount of energy that
propagates that is
carried by this field.
So therefore, the magnitude
squared of the Fourier series
coefficient actually
corresponds to the energy
that goes into each
separate diffraction order.
So in this case,
so they're called
diffraction efficiencies.
And I should have mentioned
earlier, actually,
but I forgot--
so in the case of the
sinusoidal amplitude grating,
the diffraction
efficiencies are given
by the squares of
the coefficients that
go in front of each plane wave.
So you can see that
approximately-- how much--
25% of the energy is
going into the 0 order.
It is propagating on axis.
And let's assume that
the contrast is 1.
In that case, approximately
12.5% of the energy
is going into each
diffraction order.
That is 1/8.
If I sum them up, how
much do they transmit?
25% plus 12.5% plus
[INAUDIBLE] 12.5%--
50%, right?
What happens to the other 50%?
[INAUDIBLE]?
STUDENT: I think there
possibly maybe had
a plus/minus 3 order
or something, I mean,
other orders?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: That is
plausible, but in this case,
we derived only
three orders-- the 0,
the plus 1, and the minus 1,
so there's no higher order.
What happened to the
rest of the energy?
STUDENT: Is it absorbed
depending on the grating?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
The rest of them got absorbed
or actually reflected
backwards by the opaque
parts of the grating.
So remember, this is
an amplitude grating.
It blocks part of the light.
So in this case, it's
actually blocked about 50%
of the energy.
So as the last example--
which I will not derive here,
but I will let you go over
it yourselves at home--
I did the case of a binary now.
So this is a phase grating very
similar to the surface relief
that I showed before,
but in this case,
the phase is a binary function.
So why is it binary?
Because this a grating
which is either--
the light goes either through
a tall part or a short part.
The tall part, of course,
suffers more phase delay
because the light has to go
through glass for a little bit
longer than the short part.
Therefore, if I plot the phase
of the complex transmission,
expect to see
something like this.
The part of the grating that are
taller, they give me a longer
phase delay, and of course, the
phase delay can now be tried
normalized so that it is
0 at some reference value.
And then what is the phase
delay at the long part
actually depends on the
height of this groove.
So even the height
of this groove
is such that s equals
2 pi n minus 1 over--
let me get this straight.
So delta phi equals 2
pi upon lambda times
n times s minus 2 pi over lambda
times s2, where this is s1.
This is s2.
So if I say that s1 equals s2
plus s, then what I will get
is 2 pi over lambda
times n minus 1 times s.
So you can see from here that--
so if s is given by lambda
divided by twice the index
difference between the glass
and the surrounding medium,
then the phase delay implemented
by this grating is actually pi.
So if you have a
function like this,
then, phase delay pi means
that the complex amplitude
transmission is minus
1, and phase delay 0
means that it is plus 1.
So there's is another way
to write this function.
It is 1 at half of the period,
and minus 1 the other half
of the period.
So you can actually--
it's a little bit of a
[? grind. ?] Next time
I will show you a
faster way to derive it
that you can derive the
Fourier series for this kind
of a binary phase grating,
and you'll find actually
something very interesting.
I don't know if you noticed
the animation when I showed it.
Let me play it once again.
You'll find that even orders
of this grating are actually 0,
and next time, I will
actually say a little bit more
about this.
Anyway, you find the expression
for the diffracted orders
equals to something that looks
like sine of 5 times the order.
So of course, if the order is
integral, if the order is even,
then there's no diffraction.
It turns out that
this grating has
a relatively strong diffraction
efficiency of about 40%
into the first order.
STUDENT: I've got a question.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yes?
STUDENT: How does
the polarization
of the incident plane wave
change the diffraction
efficiencies?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So
these guys were actually
in the scalar optics
approximation,
so we neglect the
effect of polarization.
To include it is actually
rather complicated business
that we may get to near
the end of this class,
but it requires something called
coupled wave theory, which
is relatively advanced.
A rule is that if that
period is relatively long,
a rule of thumb
about 10 wavelengths
or longer, the effect of
the polarization is minor.
You have a grating whose
period is 2 wavelengths,
3 wavelengths,
something like that,
then the effect is
actually significant,
and it cannot be neglected.
But in this class,
we will actually--
at least at the
beginning, we will
pretend that the
period is large enough
that we can neglect
polarization effects.
Very good question.
Practice actually
makes a big difference.
Other questions?
STUDENT: Just now, we show
one grating, which modifies
the amplitude of the wave.
So what's a physical
picture of such a grating?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So for
example, what you can do
is you can Just take
a piece of glass,
and evaporate the aluminum or
some other metal into the areas
that you want to
block the light.
So that's one way
to make the grating,
So we take a piece
of glass, then
you can evaporate
aluminum uniformly here.
Then on top of it, you can put
photoresist and patterning.
OK.
Then you can etch.
So why when you etch, you will
actually remove these parts.
What you will end up
is something like this.
Then you also remove the
rest of the photoresist.
So that would be, now,
a binary amplitude
grating because you
have aluminum blocking
the light here and
then not in here,
so the light goes through.
Yeah, as I said, this is called
a binary amplitude grating,
and you will deal with
it in the homework.
To make a grayscale, like
the one that I showed
in my calculations here,
it's actually a little bit
difficult. To make this kind
of thing is rather hard.
It can be done with sort of
proper evaporation tools,
but very hard.
So this is a rather--
it's a simple construction
that they need in order
to describe the
physics, but it's not
very easy to implement
the practice.
STUDENT: And I guess,
just to tie it to the demo
for the phase counterpart,
you can do this
by-- you saw the
interference pattern produced
by the Mach-Zehnder, right, that
there were sinusoidal fringes.
So instead of the CCD, you
could imagine putting there,
for the sensitive
polymer, for example,
like photoresist,
that will expose
that material with these
bright and dark fringes.
That basically will cause
that refractive index
in a sinusoidal
pattern, and that
will produce the phase
version of this grating that
were shown before also.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
As it turns out,
if you do what Pepe
just described-- let
me see if I get to it here.
If you do what Pepe just
described, you get two effects.
One is that the
index of refraction
changes in the exposed areas,
but also, because there is--
you can understand
this is a fluid effect.
The index of refraction
changing means
that the material becomes,
actually, slightly denser.
So this will result in
a surface undulation
in order to conserve its--
to conserve matter, the surface
will actually have to undulate.
So you end up with a grating
that is non-surface relief.
So these exposure processes
are relatively complicated.
So if we have time, I may go
into it later during the class.
But another way to do this, to
do the binary grating, which
is done very often
in practice, is using
the electron-beam lithography.
Where is my-- so
this kind of grating
is also done with
a similar process,
but using electron-beam
lithography.
So what you do is basically--
one way to do it is
you start with glass,
then you coat it with a
material that is called HSQ.
And actually, you can pattern
it using an electron beam.
You put an electron beam
resist on top, which is PMMA.
Then, using the electron beam,
you remove parts of the PMMA.
And then you etch
away these parts.
Then you end up with a
pattern that looks like this.
So HSQ is actually clear.
It's very similar to glass.
So this would be a physical
realization of the binary phase
grating.
The light is all
transparent, but the light
propagates a longer
distance inside the material
here, whereas here, it
propagates in the air.
So that's why we'll
get this effect.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
With a laser beam,
you can actually get
very small gratings.
If it is completely
periodic, then people
can make something like 100
nanometers or less easily.
So what I mean by 100 nanometers
is that this period over here
might be 100 nanometers,
even less, actually.
So of course, for
visible light, that
would be a
subwavelength grating.
It wouldn't do much.
But it could be useful, for
example, for ultraviolet light,
or for other applications where
you don't use it as a grating.
If it is nonperiodic,
very often--
we will see later in the class--
sometimes, we want to make
patterns that look like this.
OK, so this is, again, a phase
grating, but it is nonperiodic.
You can see that
the period changes.
So if the period changes
in the quadratic fashion,
this is a very
important element.
It's called a "Fresnel" Here
is, again, the French term--
"Fresnel zone plate."
This I will describe
in class later.
It's a very, very important
optical component.
But it turns out because
of this kind of pattern
it is nonperiodic, it is
not so easy to make using
electron-beam lithography.
So in that case, you
have to go to great pains
to make small features.
So in this case, it's
a little bit strange.
But because of the
nonperiodicity,
the feature sizes
here are limited
to bigger values-- so for
example, 200 to 300 nanometers.
This has to do with the
way electron beams scatter
from the photoresist.
Actually, some of
you are taking,
simultaneously, Professor
[? Bargrand's ?] class.
He goes into great detail
into this particular--
into why this is the case.
For visible light, it
is actually quite easy
to make reasonably sized
gratings with lambda
bigger than, say, five
or 10 wavelengths.
It is actually easy to
make these kind of gratings
either with optical exposure,
like Pepe described,
or with electron-beam
lithography.
There's also other
techniques, for example,
interference lithography.
There's a whole
set of techniques
that people use to
make this grating.
I don't know.
Pepe, do you know, the one that
you showed, how was it made?
STUDENT: Not really.
Not really.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: [INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT: It was the
one that you used.
Do you know?
I don't know, to be honest.
No.
I think it's a binary grating
and probably was done--
I don't think it
was done with e-beam
because it's pretty large.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: No.
No.
STUDENT: It has to do with--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: [INAUDIBLE]
suspect that way also
of making these
gratings by molding.
That's another way.
So you basically create a
very expensive negative,
like a mold.
And then you stamp--
not quite glass.
It has to be some kind
of a pliable material.
That's one way.
And then they can
also make them by--
basically, by scratching
by very accurate machines.
So there are many, many
different ways to make--
STUDENT: The dip-pen lithography
or some kind of [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: It's
reactive ion etching.
STUDENT: Dip-pen lithography?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Oh, Dip-pen.
STUDENT: Yeah.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yes.
Except dip-pen lithography
can allow you to do only--
where is it?
I lost my amplitude grating.
It can only make amplitude
gratings, not phase gratings.
Depends.
It's ink, right?
So good deposit ink.
And this way, you
can actually absorb.
You can get absorption bands.
But I don't know if you
can make phase gratings
with dip-pen lithography.
Have to look into it.
They're very popular nowadays.
Again, professor [? Bagram ?]
goes into this in more detail.
But a very popular
technique is-- it's called--
help me out here.
How do you call the
stamping technique?
STUDENT: Oh, we
call it nanoimprint.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Nanoimprint, yeah.
Nanoimprint lithography, yeah.
That's a very popular technique
to make these kind of elements
with very small
periods, actually.
People make [? 15 ?]
nanometers or less,
actually, with nanoimprint.
STUDENT: Sorry, Prof.
Do we have time for
one more question?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
I have time,
but some people have classes.
But yeah, go ahead.
STUDENT: OK, I'm just curious.
Let's say, just now, you
mentioned the sine theta cannot
be greater than 1.
So what happens if we
shine the visible light
on to a grating with a period
[INAUDIBLE] 100 nanometer?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
So I actually said it before.
Let me repeat it again.
So he's asking, what will happen
if you have a grating here,
like this, for example,
where the period lambda now
is less than the wavelength?
OK.
So, if you recall, a
planewave is of this form--
e to the i kxx
plus kyy plus kzz--
and this, we saw when
we did electromagnetics.
And we also saw that because
of the electromagnetic wave
equation, the wave
vector components here--
they have to satisfy
this equation.
OK, so now, according to the
equation that we had before,
if this is the x direction--
and let's ignore y for now.
So basically, I can
neglect this term for now.
And what we have is that the
sine factor will equal lambda
upon the period.
And it's bigger than 1.
OK, mathematically, if
I have a complex angle,
the sine can be bigger than 1.
But what does this
physically mean?
Physically, if you plug
into this equation here,
you will get that the kz
squared equals 2 pi upon lambda
squared minus 2 pi upon lambda
squared based on this equation.
When I said that kx equals
2 pi upon lambda sine theta
equals to pi upon lambda times
lambda over lambda equals 2 pi
upon lambda--
OK.
So if I do that now, I will
get that the kz squared
equals 2 pi.
And the quantity inside the
square root is less than 0,
so we'll get that the kz
now will equal plus minus.
It will become imaginary.
[INAUDIBLE] plus minus i
the square root of something
positive.
So what does this mean now?
I have a wave whose amplitude
will be like e to the i kxx.
Nothing changes here.
But then it will be plus minus
i times something positive.
Let's call this "alpha"
for gravity here.
OK, this is what
the wave will look
like after the
subwavelength grating.
So now, clearly here,
if you multiply the two
imaginary units, we
will get a real number.
So we get either exponential
decay or exponential explosion.
Physically, you cannot expect
the wave to grow exponentially.
That would mean someone
is supplying power,
and there's nothing
like that here.
So therefore, you
get a wave that
will look like e to
the minus alpha z--
there's a z here
in [INAUDIBLE]----
times e to the minus
e to the plus ikxx.
So what is this now?
The e to the minus alpha
z's an exponential decay
away from the grating.
The e do the ikx is what
we call a "surface wave."
It propagates like this.
So actually, what you
get after this grating
is you get a wave that
propagates parallel
to the grating.
I don't know if the camera
can show me on this one--
probably not.
But anyway, as you get the
wave that propagates parallel
to the grating, it is
called the "surface wave,"
but it doesn't live very long.
It decays exponentially
away from the grating.
That is actually called
an "evanescent wave."
And it is not really
part of the class.
This is a very simplified
description of what happens.
To properly do it,
I would have to take
into account polarization.
I would basically have
to be more careful
solving Maxwell's equations.
And because this class
is simple, basic optics,
I generally stay away from
those kinds of gray things.
That's why I don't
describe them in detail.
But since you asked, I gave you
a very simplified description.
We may talk about this
a bit near the end,
depending on how much time
we have left near the end.
But if we do, I will talk
about this in more detail.
It's also related
to the question
that someone has asked
before about polarization.
If you have a
subwavelength grating,
then you definitely have to
take into account the incident
polarization.
STUDENT: Yeah, actually--
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: I see our
audience is [INAUDIBLE] now.
So maybe it's time for
us to get our martinis
and the rest of the others
to get their coffee.
OK?